so quite a few of you have been debating
in my recent videos comment sections uh
the ones where i'm interviewing certain
celebrities like danny villeneuve and uh
paul dano and my personal favorite dr
michael morbius it's a beautiful thing
because morbius is great it's good i
find this all personally amusing and uh
the engagement doesn't hurt
right but i just want to be up front and
explain how i make these little videos
where it seems like i'm talking to
celebrities it's actually very simple
here's the trick you want to grow your
youtube channel to roughly 80 or 90 000
subscribers this may take a while but
once you pass 50k people basically let
you do whatever the [ __ ] you want then
email the brilliant sony studios uh
publicity team and uh tell them who you
are and what you want i have a template
email for this if you want to use that
if you want to try to get any of these
interviews yourself link in the
description down below then you're on a
list that gets circulated to other
studios uh like warner brothers and
because of covid uh
a lot of these interviews are only
conducted via zoom and i only take those
that are there was uh one time when i
had the opportunity to interview
christian bale
in france but uh i did i couldn't do
that anyways i get on the zoom call and
then to say as much as i want or can but
how much ever i'm able to say before the
publicist inevitably shuts it down some
take longer than others they're saying
that it's like the worst movie they've
ever seen they say that it sucks and i
think they should shut their [ __ ]
mouth they should shut the [ __ ] up he's
gotta drink blood he's gotta drink the
blood i love making these videos even
though i'm getting somewhat notorious
here in hollywood the other day someone
stopped me and said hey are you that guy
who [ __ ] sucks and i was like yeah
and he said i work for paramount studios
we want you to interview kevin costner
because we [ __ ] hate him so this has
been my life
lately what
you thought i'd fake those interviews
with basic editing software in order to
get internet cloud
you must think so little of me
[Music]
you